why shut down a well liked series
because actors leave creators finished
telling their stories or a network is
ready to move on here's a look at all
the TV shows that will have told the
stories they needed to by the end of
2019 but be warned spoilers ahead Legion
simply isn't the kind of show that can
go on and on forever but one thing that
possibly real possibly not real
Adventures of Dan Stevens character
David Haller are just so wildly other
there's no way creator Noah Hawley and
his writing staff could have kept up the
pace indefinitely after all the story
involves a man who spends much of his
time in a mental institution and doesn't
quite have a firm grip on reality or his
burgeoning superpowers who were the
people at the hospital third down no no
you're you're lying
it's up to the writers to advance the
story to a certain place especially
since Liam relates to the world of the
x-men Davis is evidently the mutant son
of the famed professor axe-fx announced
that a twisty-turny highly engrossing
sci-fi hits will conclude with its
upcoming third season which began airing
on June 24th fortunately it sounds like
this is all in accord with Hawley's
master plan he evidently wanted the
series to only run for three seasons
speaking at the Television Critics
Association event in February 2019
I think endings are what gives stories
meaning I always thought about this as a
complete story and they felt like three
acts of a story there's no denying that
Batman has always been a popular
character that never not brooding Bruce
Wayne and his rogues gallery of colorful
villains a bonafide pop culture fixtures
no matter how you slice her there are
decades worth of comic books but Tim
Burton films from the 80s and 90s a slew
of animated shows and of course
Christopher Nolan's truly iconic Dark
Knight trilogy and then there's Gotham a
clever reimagining of the Batman story
that chronicled the adventures of a
young Bruce Wayne and also introduced us
to younger versions of Commissioner
Gordon the Joker the penguin and the
Riddler since the show was always
building towards young Bruce's ultimate
transformation into Batman it was a
concept that eventually had to reach his
foregone conclusion evidently
recognizing that facts Fox renewed
Gotham for a fifth and decidedly final
season turned the presentation of his
2018-2019 programming slates honestly
Gotham fans should feel lucky this show
got another season at all it ranked a
not-so-great number 129 in a 2017 to
2018 TV ratings it also managed to
survivor cancer
Lygia massacre at Fox that involved xxxx
axing Brooklyn nine-nine the MEK Lucifer
and the Exorcist all in one fell swoop
fortunately Brooklyn nine-nine and
Lucifer were ultimately rescued by NBC
and Netflix respectively and Gotham got
a chance to wrap up its story on Fox on
the surface broad city was a wild and
wacky comedy about two young women
dealing with naughty characters and
situations in New York City but
underneath all those a meanness it's
five season run was low-key
groundbreaking it's arguably the first
new york-based comedy that ultimately
didn't clamor eyes New York in every
episode co-creators Abbi Jacobson and
Ilana Glazer portrayed two kooky young
women battling a grimy confusing
apathetic and ludicrously expensive Big
Apple but it's funny we'd like to report
that the sound was really subpar the
Dolby was nowhere near 5.1 ray okay and
endlessly entertaining an eccentric
comedy series broad city was at its core
all about the deep unconditional love
shared between these two best friends
broad city perfectly encapsulated our
friendship often propelled G through
your 20s particularly when you're
flailing in the big city and on your own
for the very first time
ultimately the co-stars and co-creators
aged out of that period in their lives
and so did their characters that's why
the show had to come to an end as
Jacobson told TV Line the show was
always really about what New York is
like in your 20s from these two specific
points of view it's a flash in the pan
kind of thing and we wanted to stay true
to that the Big Bang Theory's gang of
socially awkward California scientists
always managed to bring in huge numbers
even at the end of its 11th season in
fact it was the top-rated show on
broadcast TV for the 2017-2018 season in
advance of the show's 12th season the
season in which the show's surpassed
years and became the longest-running
multi-camera sitcom in history TV execs
began negotiating seasons 13 and 14 and
that's when our Jim Parsons bold despite
the fact that he was being paid roughly
1 million dollars per episode
the portray quirky genius Sheldon Cooper
a well deserved salary to be sure
according to Entertainment Weekly the
four-time Emmy winner effectively said
no to 50 million dollars when he turned
down two more seasons according to
Deadline
Big Bang co-creator and executive
producer Chuck Lorre gathered the cast
in his office after a table read in
August 2018 thus when a tearful Parsons
taught his cast mates
intended to lead the show at the end of
the season and then Laurie announced the
12 season would in fact be the last one
for everybody
he preferred ending the Big Bang Theory
altogether rather than continue on
without Jim Parsons or Sheldon Cooper
for that matter
HBO's monster hits Game of Thrones was
quite possibly the last true appointment
of viewing to ever air on television in
the age of Netflix binge watching and
DVRs millions gathered to watch the show
when it first aired on HBO go on Sunday
nights both to avoid online spoilers and
to immediately find out what was
happening with Jon Snow the Lannisters
and the Narrows Targaryen the mother of
dragons based on the series of
best-selling fantasy novels by george RR
martin the Westeros saga reeled viewers
in from its very first episode in 2011
but the eighth season which consisted of
six oversized episodes was definitely
the show's last at least two audiences
finally know who was destined to sit on
the Iron Throne
no one
but why would HBO force millions of
people to live in a cold empty world
without the promise of a new Game of
Thrones episode well the show reportedly
concluded because season 8 was the end
of the calculated storytelling plan
concocted by show creators David Benioff
and DB Weiss in 2016 a Benioff told
deadlines from pretty close to the
beginning we talked about doing this in
70 to 75 hours to that send the Game of
Thrones certainly wasn't like other TV
shows which often consists of
self-contained episodes or season-long
plot arcs as Benioff explained we're
trying to sell one cohesive story with a
beginning middle and end whether or not
they succeeded as something you'll
ultimately have to decide for yourself
at some point History Channel realized a
historically based TV programming could
include more than just World War two
documentaries in 2013 the channel delved
into scripted shows for the first time
with Vikings possibly the most violent
TV series that's also ostensibly
educational the drama explored the lives
families and seafaring fights of 8th
century Norse warrior Ragnar lothbrok
and his kin it's just like Game of
Thrones except possibly sort of real
yeah
creator and writer Michael Hurst bassist
show on the written sagas of buff Brock
so Vikings are sorta kinda based on a
true story and a true story that ends
all her set out to do was tell the
complete tale and over the course of six
well-regarded seasons he did just that
the decision to end Vikings was
ultimately his own in January 2019 he
told variety I always knew I wanted the
show to go and more or less where it
would end if I was given the opportunity
we stopped shooting the final episode in
November last year and I felt that I'd
said all I needed to say about Ragnar
and his sons USA has established itself
as a major player in quality cable
television offering viewers plenty of
breezy almost airless dramas they
usually involve some elements of the law
and lots of extremely attractive people
the network's slate of hits include
psych white color Royal Pains and suits
the last of which centers around Mike
Ross portrayed by Patrick Jay Adams
he's a fiercely intelligent man and
quite a brilliant attorney despite the
fact that he doesn't even have a law
degree to his name winning case after
case while maintaining his secret Mike
soon meets his match in paralegal Rachel
Zane portrayed by Megan Markov the
show's juicy legal and romantic
storylines brought in millions of fans
and according to the Sun a certain
Prince Harry was among them when Marco
began dating Prince Harry in 2016 is
spelled the eventual end of the show as
you probably know the couple fell in
love and got married in a royal wedding
for the ages in 2018 all that I am I
give to you presumably because she'd be
living in England and devoting her life
to charity work and public appearances
Marco left suits at the end of the
show's seventh season Adams evidently
figured that was a good time to leave -
and suits writer crafted a sweet exit
for the couple they got married and
moved to Seattle to run a law firm
you're the husband I've always wanted
and I can't wait to begin her attention
suits returned for season eight and 2018
befell two of his main characters and
the departure of mark Willem brass
proved too much of a loss to weather
producers called a choosing to end this
show in 2019 after the ninth and final
season of ten episodes now they're
reportedly focusing on Pearson a suit
spin-off starring Tina torrez's
character HBO isn't the only place to
find quality programming on a cable
network for a few extra bucks a month
every
years show time has also made a name for
itself with critically acclaimed and
award-winning fare like homeland that
shameless ray Donovan and the affair in
2017 Showtime debuted Smith a dark
gritty comedy from the mind of actress
Frankie Shaw the mr. robot co-star
created wrote directed and starred as
Bridget a titular single South Boston
mother with a sex drive and a social
life I'm sorry no I'm sorry no I'm sorry
the show attracted a sizable audience
and the second season was quickly
ordered but some serious controversy
eventually reared its head and it
directly led to smells early and abrupt
demise in December 2018 smell fighters
reported to the Writers Guild of America
that show had allegedly separated
staffers by race meanwhile co-star
Samara weaving claimed that Shore for
SATA film a nude scene
despite her no nudity contract clause in
March 2019 the network said in a
statement that after weighing a variety
of factors Showtime and society that's
milf will not move forward for a third
season and that's as they say was that
transparent aggressively evolved over
the course of three seasons the quiet
ultra subtle Amazon series took on a
premise that never been fully explored
an American television Jeffrey Tambor
starred as Maura Phi Furman a college
professor who finally start living a
truth she identifies as a woman in other
words she's a trans parents over the
course of four seasons transparent
ambitiously expanded into a show that
was not only about gender identity but
sexual and cultural identity -
particularly in how the fireman family
explored their Jewish faith and
background but Morris journey remained
the core theme of the show
that is until producers and Amazon fire
Tambor the company launched an
investigation after cast member traced
the sets accused Tambor of multiple acts
of sexual harassment and one instance of
assaults Tambor's assistant Vaughn bars
also accused the actor of inappropriate
behavior it ran the gamut of sexual
harassment physical harassment and
verbal abuse constantly with Tom Borg on
the show's writers decided to wrap up
this series with a special two-hour
finale that's set to air on Amazon in
September 2019
according to Variety the death of Mora
will figure prominently in the storyline
and the episode is actually going to be
a musical if you can believe it let's
take it from the top
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and at
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]